Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P Here is a
voicemail which argues this
is actually very interesting
that what Putin is doing is no different than what
American settlers did to the Native Americans of
the United States. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4:
Have you gotten any street smarts yet? No. Have
you figured out what the difference is between
what Putin is doing and what our forefathers when
they came here and they just killed everybody from
the property that was here? OK? Like indigenous
people, there's no fucking difference. Do you
honestly understand the United States? There are
no United States, this 50 different countries.
In North America, they do whatever they want,
and the government will do a damn thing.
And we're supposed to be the United States.
Are you fucking kidding me? Are you naive?
Speaker 1: So the person does seem unhinged, but
part of the argument that he seems to be making is
what Putin is doing in Ukraine is no more right or
wrong than what our forefathers did in the United
States. Well, I mean, listen. Circumstances are
different, but there is a grain of truth to that.
If someone had been able to stop our forefathers,
they probably would have. And so the fact that
the people who came from Europe to colonize
the United States were able to do it because
they didn't meet enough resistance isn't a
very good reason to say what Putin is doing
isn't really that bad or should be allowed to
go on it. I mean, maybe the guy's making a good
point. But when I hear that, I say, Oh, well, I
mean, if the natives had been better equipped,
they might have rejected the colonial settlers
from Europe. That's not a reason to let Putin
take whatever the hell he wants. Kind of an
interesting, I mean, a very angry person,
very unhinged, but making an interesting
point that I think should be considered but
may be considered in a different way than he
wants me thinking about it. Interesting stuff.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Iowa and New Hampshire are not guaranteed to
be the first primaries of 2024. We'll tell you
what's going on and why. We will also talk about
the extension to the federal travel mask mandate,
which applies on planes and elsewhere. And lastly,
Gov. Greg Abbott of Texas doing quite a quite a
stunt with a bus of migrants going to Washington,
D.C. We'll tell you what's going on and what
they hope to get out of it. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show.
Sign up at join Packman dot com.